welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today we had
a pretty busy Monday obviously lots of
bad news coming out for Donald Trump and
lots of things Donald Trump did that he
thought we're gonna make his life so
much easier but in fact they're really
just gonna make it a living nightmare
and one of those things was at the DOJ
ordered former White House Counsel Don
McGann
to not comply with a congressional
subpoena then Don McGann through his
attorneys made it clear to Congress that
he was not going to be showing up today
Tuesday for the hearing that they wanted
to have he wasn't going to give his
testimony because the DOJ told him not
to comply that is called obstruction
folks you you can't do that your
suborning that that's exactly what just
happened with Don McGann Democrats
obviously want the opportunity to speak
to Don Magan because according to the
Muller report McGann played a central
role in telling Muller and the
investigators about potential
obstruction of justice on behalf of the
President of the United States this is
obstruction that McGann claims Donald
Trump committed or was involved directly
in so Democrats rightfully want to know
more they need some more answers on this
they need to see if there was intent to
obstruct justice because if there was
then they absolutely 100% could move
forward with articles of impeachment
against the president based on
obstruction of justice now don't get me
wrong they're already sitting on a
plethora of information on which they
could impeach the president but they
want more they want to make it foolproof
they want to hit him with all of the
charges that they possibly could which
is completely unnecessary I you look at
the poll numbers right now a majority of
people do think that the Muller report
made Trump look worse made it seem like
he did commit some kind of crime that
crime is likely obstruction of justice
Don McGann got subpoenaed
he is still also a lawyer with the Jones
day law firm so it would be interesting
to know what Jones Day has to say about
one of their own lawyers disregarding a
subpoena thinking that they are above
the law you can't ignore a subpoena
folks I mean let's get that out of the
way right now if you get subpoenaed you
are legally obligated to show up and the
House of Representatives does have a
mechanism to force this they subpoenaed
McGann he said I'm not showing up they
can send the sergeant-at-arms to go and
arrest him throw him in the little bitty
jail that they have right there at the
House of Representatives until he agrees
to testify they have the authority and
the power to do that but they're not
going to and that's the most
disappointing thing out of all of this
is that they're not going to they're
just gonna set up yet another legal
battle against the president the
Democrats are likely going to win just
like they're winning the other ones but
times a factor right okay they've got
what 18 months 18 months before the
election and if they lose their majority
in that election it's not likely but it
is possible obviously
then suddenly any talk of impeachment is
out the window it will never happen at
that point so rather than having to send
this to court get the courts to enforce
it they'll side with the Democrats then
the president appeals and appeals until
he gets all the way to the Supreme Court
that could take more than 18 months and
I know based on some of the other cases
that we have already seen the judges
typically do expedite these but we can't
guarantee something like that would
happen every single time especially when
you have a White House filing a lawsuit
or Democrats filing a lawsuit at every
possible opportunity use the mechanisms
you have in place throw McGann in your
tiny little Jail and wait for him to
start singing because McGann's made it
clear he actually did want to testify
but he's kind of between a rock and a
hard
place he thinks that it's best to listen
to the president rather than listening
to Congress he seems to forget that at
the end of the day Congress has just as
much if not more in this particular
situation power then the President does
and they can make his life hell if they
choose to do so and I think at this
point it's time for them to choose to do
so not just because of McGann's
testimony either but to send a message
it's time to tell this White House that
you are not above the law that your
administration officials are not above
the law and that when this branch of the
government that has the responsibility
of oversight of the executive branch
comes calling you have to pick up the
phone you don't have a choice
unfortunately leadership in the House of
Representatives right now is at least
giving the appearance of being
exceptionally weak not saying they are
exactly weak but by not impeaching
they're coming across as weak they may
have some kind of grand strategy that we
don't know about they may be playing a
longer game they may have an ace up
their sleeves that we don't even know
exists but by not knowing those things
it makes them look weak it makes them
look like they're afraid I mean we've
heard them say that oh the public
doesn't support impeachment who cares
the public didn't support bailing out
the big banks but you did that anyway
the public didn't support the Republican
tax scam but they did that anyway the
public didn't support the Republicans
health care plan two years ago but they
tried to do that anyway since when does
public opinion actually weigh on the
minds of members of Congress you guys
every day do stuff that the public says
that's a bad idea we want this instead
you never listen to them and then on
this one issue where you shouldn't
listen to them you're using the public
as an excuse to not go forward with it
just do it just do it that's it
there's no questioning this there's no
being mealy-mouthed there's no being
wishy-washy this needs to happen not
just to get McGann's testimony but to
restore some sense of order and
accountability to Congress one of
today's sponsors is impeach the card
slap game you can't slap Donald Trump in
real life but you can slap them in this
hilarious fast-paced two-player card
game and you can get it for ten percent
off when you go to david pakman.com
slash impeach impeach the card game is
awesome for parties or when you're
having a few drinks I've been playing it
with some friends of mine it combines
clever satire about the Trump
administration with really funny
high-quality cartoon artwork all in a
very lively card game that's easy to
learn but it stays interesting every
time you play it because of how well
designed it is and how much thought went
into the humor and the political
commentary impeach the cards slap game
is perfect if you're looking for
something fun and casual to do with your
politically minded friends or family
members it'll make a perfect gift for
anyone you know who has a sense of humor
about Donald Trump don't forget that
Father's Day is coming up and when you
go to david pakman.com slash impeach not
only will you get 10% off the game you
can also get 10% off all of the other
hilarious clothing and accessories in
their online store t-shirts coffee mugs
tote bags featuring funny political
cartoons about trump that you can't find
anywhere else get a super fun witty gift
for yourself or someone you know whether
it's impeach the card slap game or
anything else in the gift shop and get
10% off all of it when you go to david
pakman.com slash impeach